[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2013 Mercedes entered the compact SUV
market with the GLA now it's gotten the
facelift we're testing the sportiest
member of the GLA family AMG gla45
4matic one of its special attributes is
its giant front air vents the fender
skirts have been redesigned to reduce
friction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
at the back the eye catchers are the new
diffuser insert the decorative chrome
elements and the separation edge on the
spoiler
[Music]
under the hood there's a 2-liter
four-cylinder turbo engine with 280
kilowatts of power 475 Newton meters of
torque pushed the driver back in his
seat when the car accelerates the AMG
gla45 goes from zero to 100 kilometers
an hour in 4.4 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
with a price tag of 60,000 euros this
version is twice as expensive as the
basic GLA model and the difference is
really apparent on the interior
everything here is sporty and luxurious
and the AM cheesehead writing is visible
everywhere like a metal on a proudly
inflated chest
with the optional AMG drivers package
the car can reach speeds of up to 270
kilometers an hour in addition to the
driving modes Comfort Sport and Sport
Plus there's also a race setting all of
them can be customized to suit drivers
individual preferences
[Music]
[Applause]
is on the car tester I know Dyson over
says that the exhaust button in the
central console is especially important
it's what turns the GLA into an AMG with
its characteristic sound line hold as
impressed with a highly precise handling
that responds to every millimeter you
turn the wheel but the car doesn't like
driving over lane dividers the motor
also responds to the slightest touch of
the gas pedal it's got plenty of pickup
and it sounds like a sports car but the
GLA is not only fun to drive in the
country it's also great for the city
that's because of its compact size in
dirt or off-road situations all-wheel
drive really comes to the fore
[Music]
[Applause]
compact cars are being sticks I note
says that compact cars the entry-level
models based on the a-class are
particularly important for Daimler since
2012 2 million of the vehicles have been
sold you won't find any comparable car
right now that's more fun to drive than
the 280 kilowatt AMG and anyone
intending to try one out should take
driving lessons at speeds of over 250
kilometers an hour the road gets mighty
narrow once when a drumstick I'm ha
Mitsu ina compact means I'm a gun
shooting
[Music]
by Nava car tester Emmanuel Schaefer
says car makers always come up with
something unusual to introduce a new
model Skoda has chosen an art museum in
Stockholm for the car rocks world
premiere the arty Parag hosts
exhibitions and can be rented for events
like this go to premier more than 350
journalists from 29 countries travel to
Stockholm to meet the new car rock Skoda
unveiled the successor to the Yeti with
plenty of special effects and flare
designers have changed the cars look the
boxiness of the Yeti is so yesterday and
with the new lines came a new name the
car rock the word is derived from an
indigenous Alaskan language as is Kodiak
and it's a combination of the concepts
Auto and era
schooled as head of development
Christians Trueba says that they've
reinvented the Yeti from the ground up
it has a new platform based on
Volkswagens MQB toolkit that enables the
two car makers to collaborate on
development the car rack shares its
technology with another VW Group member
the sayeda tikka both roll off the
assembly line at the same time
connectivity and safe smartphone use and
driving are key features for many
potential buyers school 2 CEO Ben Hart
Meyer says digital technology is
important today and Skoda wants to make
cars into a perfect 3rd place
after home and office we want drivers to
have the same opportunities to
communicate that they have in those
places
thanks to scho to connect the vehicle is
always linked to the Internet that way
it can provide not just entertainment
but also information and support
suggesting alternative routes for
example or automatically making
emergency calls faux LED headlights with
integrated day running lights are
available as an option the running
lights also double as indicators the
engines haven't changed much they've
already made appearances in a range of
VW models and can deliver between 85 and
140 kilowatts of power to petrol engines
and three diesel will be available to
start Nov thank Manuel says the car rock
is much roomier than it looks with the
seats folded down more than 1500 liters
of space are available and with the
variable loading system you can haul
cargo of all sizes and shapes what's
called the Vario flex system is composed
of three individual rear seats that can
be positioned separately or taken out
entirely that gives the car rack a
maximum cargo space a 1810 liters the
new Skoda car rack will show up in
dealer showrooms in autumn of this year
prices haven't been sent yet but it's
estimated a basic model will sell for
about 21 thousand euros
[Music]
BMW is freshening up its two series
including the 230 I convertible the
ragtop model is a perfect summer car its
185 kilowatt inch and goes from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in 5.9 seconds the
new convertible will be available for a
sticker price of 46 thousand euros in
Germany in July
Volvo is bringing out the second
generation of its xc60 it's been
redesigned to be one of the safest cars
in the world at speeds of up to 130
kilometers an hour it can be partially
driven automatically the car is
available in two gasoline and two diesel
versions and one plug-in hybrid model
[Music]
it's been hard some denim on show
Assenmacher is testing a Honda clarity
her first fuel cell powered car in
Denmark because it's the European
country with the best network of
hydrogen gas stations it's important
that clarity fuel set the Japanese
carmaker has developed a vehicle that
produces no toxic emissions runs on
electricity recharges rapidly and has
the range of a gasoline or diesel
powered vehicle all the advantages and
none of the disadvantages of a
conventional internal combustion engine
when destined Michele's first impression
of a Honda clarity fuel cell is very
good
the interior is attractive and the car
is very comfortable and quiet Honda's
environmentally friendly flagship as an
elegant stately design ultra-thin LED
headlights underscore the futuristic
appearance that we can expect from Honda
models in the future the fuel cell stack
has been reduced in size so now it fits
in the engine compartment
the Honda clarity is all about
aerodynamics special alloy wheel rims
and the hatchback roofline reduce wind
resistance air curtains let the air
stream smoothly past the wheel arches
hundra to improve the clarity zero
dynamics Honda has added air intakes in
front and backs as michelle air streams
in at the front and leaves again through
an opening at the back past the wheel
that means less air turbulence the
clarity has room for five people the
back seat has ample space
but the trunk is a real problem the two
big hydrogen tanks leave only 334 liters
of space for cargo and the backseat
can't be put down almost 80% of the
interior surface consists of
environmentally friendly materials the
dashboard and the interior cladding on
the doors are made of recycled polyester
plant materials are used for the floor
mats and roof lining as with most
alternative power systems this car is
very quiet to drive says Michelle the
transmission is direct and Michelle
especially likes that the car coasts
rather than starting the brake as soon
as she takes her foot off the gas all
slides how does a fuel cell car work
actually to make it simple a fuel cell
car is an electric car that doesn't need
to be plugged in it has its own power
plant onboard in the fuel cell stack in
the engine compartment oxygen and water
react producing electrical energy and
the ash from this oxidation is pure
water a turbo compactor pumps air and
with it oxygen through the fuel cell the
hydrogen comes from two pressure tanks
Dustin refueling the Honda clarity is
just like refueling a car with a
gasoline engine sense Michelle open the
latch and lower this little switch and
set the fuel nozzle on it
when you secure the lever air is shot
into the tank to measure how full it is
and how much hydrogen needs to be added
filling up takes about three minutes the
full cells and a buffer battery under
the front seats produce a maximum of 130
kilowatts and 300 Newton meters of
torque when the car slows or breaks
energy is recouped in the battery like
in a normal electric car
[Music]
[Applause]
Honda says one tank of hydrogen will
take the clarity more than 700
kilometers but 600 or 650 kilometers is
probably more realistic the car
accelerates from 0 to 100 in 9 seconds
[Music]
when you accelerate says Michelle you
can really hear the car sucking in air
from the outside maybe you can't hear it
well in this film but here inside the
car it sounds strange but pretty cool
when you step on the gas a hissing sound
drowns out the hum of the electric motor
that's compressed air being forced into
the fuel cell and water vapor leaving
the car through the underbody the Honda
clarity won't be seen on German streets
in the near future there simply aren't
enough hydrogen service stations Honda
is one of five car manufacturers taking
part in the initiative high five which
wants to promote knowledge and
acceptance of fuel cell technology
you
[Music]
twenty-eight years ago the land rover
discovery started out as a large family
friendly off-road vehicle and it's for
generations have attracted more than 1.2
million buyers we're the fifth
generation the vehicle has been
revolutionized car tester and elite
Zimmerman says that depending on the
model the new discovery is up to 480
kilos lighter but it still weighs about
two tons with that weight it does hug
curves tight but that's not what the
discovery is about it's a big car and
the suspension is very comfortable it
feels a bit like being on a cruise ship
but overall it works out well the Sam
Puckett is often first to me the
discovery is so much lighter because
engineers designed it without a steel
frame the chassis is self-supporting and
made completely of aluminum
we tested the top version of this big
diesel car it costs around 70,000 euros
that gets you lots of interior luxury
and acceleration from 0 to 100 in just
over 8 seconds
[Music]
Lyne trova andre says the land rover can
look back on one of the longest off-road
histories in the automotive sector but
is the new discovery sacrificing
tradition to the latest trends is it
just another SUV or has it remained a
true off-roader we'll test that in a
special location underground in a former
mine I'm well prepared in an emergency I
want to be found quickly before the car
goes down to the pits it has to ascend
exploiting all of its 28 centimeters of
clearance an air suspension system that
gives it 6 centimeters more clearance
than the model with conventional coil
springs the discovery first shows what
it can do when it leaves the road with
the optional 1,400 euro off-road package
handling can be optimized to suit
various types of terrain an off-road
reduction helps to drive the car forward
slowly but with lots of power
[Music]
decided pantry says that the 20-degree
slope feels steep the discovery can
handle 30 degree grades with no problem
mr. dices got my gold 5 the discoveries
electronics assist the driver that makes
navigating even challenging obstacles
like these steps child's play in gangs
that's Andre says that's unlike a
classic off-road vehicle where the
driver has to choose which drive he
wants to use the discoveries fine
sensors can tell which wheel has the
most traction and where to deliver the
power versus rotgut envoy idealized on
hinchik moss
back above ground the almost 5 meter
high vehicle shows off its design lots
of details including the curve in the
hatchback harken back to the discoveries
past de nom de Andre says the new land
rover lives up to the name discovery
when the electric trunk lid is raised
you discover this drawbridge like
element that can be lowered by pressing
this button oh no my one tough on con so
that got to get heavy cargo out of the
bag I thought that we Botstein con Dan
Hanson off no vital it also has an
additional function no matter how heavy
you are you can use it as a two-person
picnic bench y'all its picnic Bank event
you can adjust the height with the air
suspension system
what of Yama's and here is a third row
of seats hungry wants to take a closer
look at that
let's check out a knock on Decker due to
the tis its kaya Wendy charge me it's my
niece's on so I'm not can you get to
those seats yes
how does keep someone yes you can well
Jana ionic dance comfortable laundry
says that it's time to very comfortable
here but it's okay considering that he's
seated in the third rot that the seat
remains locked in its most forward
position which means that he has a lot
of legroom by Heights quiet there's
sufficient Headroom as well one-nothing
it's not like being in the cheap seats
you know he's even got his own little
storage space you know access to one of
the cars the nine USB ports you have to
say well done Land Rover Land Rover
the front seats of course are also
anything but cheap in front of the
central armrest there's a command center
with the air suspension the off-road
mode and gear shifting wheel
[Music]
the HSE luxury option comes with two
panorama sunroof as a mission tonight
Andre says the discovery left a lasting
impression on him above all because the
designers haven't tried to make this
off-road vehicle into an everyday street
car it drives okay but it's not a sports
car that's the way it should be it's
performance off-road together with the
flexibility of the Interior and third
row of seats really bold Andre over
those are all factors in the discoveries
favors in Discovery special
I look now at an iconic car that has a
huge following car tester Christophe
Bauer is out and about Anna Volkswagen
Beetle convertible exploring the
mountain plateau of Leveroni in Italy
the Beetle Cabriolet was manufactured
right up until 1980 it was first
designed back before the Second World
War the Scopuli Christophe Bauer says
these days the convertible is the
epitome of freedom and independence but
in the 1930s things were different those
who could afford it but a hardtop sedan
preferably with a chauffeur there were
always soft tops but they tended to be
very basic and quite a bit cheaper so
the beetle which was always intended as
a car for the masses obviously plan to
have a convertible right from the start
the first prototype for the soft-top
beetle was built in 1936
although series production would not
follow for many years after the war it
was the hardtop models for the first
Volkswagen that rolled off the assembly
lines at Wolfsburg in 1949 finally the
beetle Cabriolet took to the road and
many were keen to get in on the action
like the first 60 VW sedans the pre-war
soft top prototype was built in the
garage of Ferdinand Porsches villa in
Stuttgart a Beetle Cabriolet was always
based on the most expensive and powerful
version of the Beetle sedan that was
currently available but this model from
1979 for example has the 1.6 liter
engine from the VW 1303 s which was
first manufactured in 1972 and was the
most powerful beetle engine ever to go
into series production it goes from zero
to a hundred kilometers in 20 seconds
yeah nothing to get excited about there
but focusing on power and speed was
always a taboo for VW their priority was
reliability that's a shame a little more
power would certainly suit the 1303
convertible the 1979 Super Beetle as
it's known had the best beetle
suspension of all time distinguished by
a coil spring and strut front suspension
this car that is more than 40 years old
and with a pre-war design takes bends
with astounding ease either the fog
Christoph says the handling of the VW
Beetle is very special the steering is
unbelievably responsive effortless
because the engine is in the back it
powers the rear axles and the wheels
directly providing endless traction
cancion owner and heir
the modern chassis that was introduced
to the VW 1302 in 1970 allows for more
space in the trunk thanks to the longer
front from 1970 to the 1303 came with a
taller curved windshield to comply with
US law which required a greater distance
between the driver and the windscreen
the modern style padded dashboard was
another concession to passive safety at
the rear an air-cooled 1.6 liter boxer
engine provides 50 horsepower
Isak i noise the exterior of the 1303
convertible reveals little technical
progress there are a few details like
the chunky taillights that earned the
nickname elephant's feet but otherwise
the basic shape of the VW Beetle hardly
changed in 30 years of production but in
the interior there were big changes
introduced in the 70s plastic everywhere
in those days that was state-of-the-art
of course but today you'd love to just
have a little chrome here and there
instead but the robust soft top design
was retained the roof can be shut in a
few simple steps keeping out that summer
rain simple and fun and practical right
from the start the soft-top version of
the beetle cost around 1/3 more than the
sedan still sales for the cabrillo a
boom for over three decades
long advocated for years the soft-top
beetle was the world's best-selling
convertible during 31 years of
production over 330 thousand vehicles
rolled off the assembly lines only in
1991 was it overtaken by the VW Golf
when it was announced in 1978 the
production of the Beetle Cabriolet was
to end fans stormed the VW dealers to
snap up the last remaining cars which is
pretty rare in the fast-moving
automotive industry so the VW
convertible is definitely a milestone in
automotive history driving with the wind
in your hair the Beetle Cabriolet proved
convertibles don't have to be an
unaffordable luxury and in so doing has
guaranteed that the soft-top
lives on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]